ja das hier ist einfach die länge meine
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft folge minecraft
wächst ja hallo erst mal und zwar habe
ich ja gestern bzw heute in der hydro
folge ich weiß es nicht ganz genau
gesagt dass immer dienstags eine facts
folge kommt weil ich das jetzt einfach
mal so als schaue einführen wollte mehr
oder weniger ich habs jetzt eine längere
zeit pausiert habe jetzt wieder drei
folgen aufgenommen das kommt echt super
gut bei euch an
deswegen dachte ich mir dieses unglück
zu wissen in minecraft setzt jetzt
einfach mal täglich dienstags
wöchentlich dienstags immer fort ich
glaube wir gerade auch so richtig
komisch rum und ja dachte ich einfach
das beste seiner art serie mache meine
stimme ist immer noch ein bisschen weg
das hört man ich mir noch ein bisschen
krank aber ich habe es einfach bock dass
sie aufzunehmen da ich ja dadurch auch
immer was neues dazu lernen und ich dann
natürlich auch was beibringen und bla
bla bla bla bla jedenfalls seht ihr
schon oder lucanet gar keins kindern ich
habe so eine tolle rüstung aber dass das
eher was mit dem effekt mit dem ersten
vergleich zu tun und zwar erst mal warum
habe ich keine keinen skin ich habe kein
internet portale störung je telekom ich
liebe dich alles internet telefon
fernsehen weg ich kann nichts machen die
aus als eben hier aufnehmen und lernen
was anderes kann ich echt nicht machen
bis morgen mittag 15 uhr wahrscheinlich
gehen dauert diese störung an
deswegen ist auch bei christmas kraft
konnte ich mit aufnehmen und so was
alles und ja keine ahnung also es wird
auf jeden fall morgen wieder besser sein
dann wird auf jeden fall die videos auch
wieder perfekt kommen und alles mögliche
deswegen wenn ihr das video gesehen bin
ich wahrscheinlich gab ein kumpel und
hab das dann da hochgeladen
weil ich dann eben vorbei gefahren bin
und das daneben das internet ausgenutzt
habe aber na gut da soll ich das thema
sein ich will euch nicht voll heulen ich
wollte nur sagen dass wenn es endet ein
bisschen kaputt ist zurzeit deswegen
kann der eventuell ein paar
schwierigkeiten auftreten bei videos etc
übrigens erst mal leitet joachim lucas
till lieber ein bisschen mehr zeit und
macht das dann alles ein bisschen
schöner hier bei den effekt deswegen
weil die zeit genommen hat hier einfach
mal so ein bisschen die welt sonst ist
ihr das soll so nach tannenbäume
aussehen also ein bisschen verschönern
ich habe so ein bisschen schnee über
linke papier zum schneeberg gebe ich ein
paar pferdchen geholt das sind die
amadeus unterbringen das ist sabrina das
amadeus kennt die amadeus und sabri
woher amoled bibi und tina kaufmann
erfand arena
nein jedenfalls sollte die beiden
heranholen damit er sie also ein
bisschen das sollen eigentlich rentiere
sein japan rentiere damit auch leichter
stoff getrennt
die wollte auf jeden fall holen so zum
feeling so ein bisschen jeder serie
wisst sowie gehen auf weihnachten zwar
gar nicht so sauer denn alba der erste
weg kommt von mut hunter und zwar meint
der mut hunter das ist ein fakt ist wenn
ich eine gefärbte rüstungen habe was ich
hier habe und die dann einfach offenen
kessel also offenen kolding mit wasser
drin rechts ich mache dass sich die
rüstung dann wieder entfärbt weil ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob man da sonst
irgendeiner form hinkriegen kann
jedenfalls funktioniert das und zwar
kann ich einfach rechtspflege
rechtsklick rechts und jetzt da kein
wasser mehr drin jetzt hole ich mal eben
noch ein bisschen wasser hier nochmal
rechtsweg und nochmal rechtsweg ich
glaube es geht jetzt noch einmal und
dann jetzt wieder leer
dann muss man halt nachfüllen und das
ist halt eigentlich relativ easy peasy
dadurch einfach mal den die farbe von
der rüstung unter zu nehmen ob man das
jetzt wirklich will weil wenn man sich
eine rüstung fährt will man eigentlich
nicht so gern die farbe irgendwie wieder
runternehmen vor allem weil die rüstung
relativ schnell kaputt ist bei einer
leder rüstung aber es funktioniert auf
jeden fall und das war halt der erste
effekt machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
zweiten effekt und zwar diesmal wieder
ein ganz simpler grundwissen fact und
zwar ganz einfach ihr kennt diese katzen
einfach aus allen wüsten sie gibt es
überall
und zwar wenn irgendein team daran
schmeißt oder wenn ihr einfach mal einen
kaktus stirbt oder sowas und ich fragte
meine ganzen sachen hin
der kaktus macht alle sachen kaputt ich
meist etwas gegen und die sache ist
kaputt egal ob sieg ist ist ein diamant
schwert oder die lust den claim-block
alles geht einfach kaputt an diesem
kaktus und es ist quasi genauso man kann
einen kaktus quasi als männer benutzten
genauso wie irgend einen lover sie
irgendwo eine ecke vollem haus und das
ist jetzt also die diskussion würdig
grünkohl croft es könnte doch alle schon
ja aber es gibt immer noch eine lola
berichten
es gibt immer noch leute die das ganze
noch nicht kennen deswegen stelle hier
fakten vor die für die breite
öffentlichkeit sind das heißt nicht
unbedingt jetzt sachen die unbedingt in
der 1.7 82 was nur was vorstellen was
noch keiner weiß weil jeder weiß schon
irgendwie irgendetwas was ich mir
vorstelle
deswegen sachen gehen kaputt am kaktus
und dass das die länge eines ja das hier
ist einfach die länge meine kommen wir
zum dritten fake tschuldigung wenn in
den letzten beiden facts meine stimme in
die totale beisteuert war das wusste ich
gar nicht hatte irgendwie beim putzen
gerade als ich mein mischpult mal wieder
von ganzen staub entfernt hab hier ist
irgendwie weiß nicht ob ich den pegel
oder irgendwie ein bisschen den level
kegler wir sind zu hoch gestellt
deswegen weil ich vielleicht ein
bisschen übersteuern tut mir leid an der
stelle
dieser effekt wurde mir zugesendet von
einer person dessen name ich nicht mehr
weiß wie das konto gelöscht wurde bei
google+
wie bei google+ plus kommentare heißt es
glaube ich post einträge weise nicht ihr
können bei google+ folgen da steht immer
in der beschreibung
da poste ich auch videos dabei ist
scheißegal und zwar könnt ihr ganz
einfach delhi petz hier auf wasser
platzieren ihr wisst ihr wisst bescheid
und zwar können wir ganz einfach blöcke
draufsetzen und zwar tue ich jetzt
einfach mal sand auf passanten block der
fällt runter allerdings ja wenn ich
jetzt endlich die zerstörungskraft der
sand runter wenn ich allerdings das
wasser darunter wegnehme geht zwar dass
willi pad weg allerdings bleibt der sand
drauf
warum habe ich den überhaupt gesetzt und
auch wenn ich das jetzt wieder wegmachen
da unten jetzt quasi wieder das wasser
ist bleibt das drauf ich kann dir jetzt
auch ein pfeil gegen schießen und es
bleibt drauf und ich kann dagegen
springen alles möglich ich kann mich da
sogar drauf steht
ich kann mich ja sogar drauf stellen
passiert nix wenn ich einen blog davon
abbau passiert auch nichts es passiert
erst was wenn ich denn irgendwie mit
anderen blöcken verbindung touren zwar
fällt er dann runter und dann fällt das
ganze andere auch unter finde ich recht
witzig kann man irgendwie ein paar
winzige fallen mit bau und irgendwie
sowas dass der sand einfach schweben
kann das haben sich immer schon einige
leute gefragt wie kann man machen das
dann schwebt jetzt wisst ihr bescheid so
meine lieben freunde kommen wir zum
vierten bzw dem fun fact worauf er
wieder gewartet habt uns war dieser fand
fällt diesmal gar nicht mal so witzig
guck mal meinem eine tolle therme ist
immer noch am start ich glaube ich lass
dir einfach hier so eine coole therme
dass wir es jeder folge so ein bisschen
was behalten weil ich nicht so eine
therme finde ich cool übrigens nächste
folgen werde ich das erstmal wieder
abreißen die weihnachtsdeko weil die
stört mich ein bisschen zumindest die
hier auf dem platz vier weil das hier
stört mich alles ein bisschen und zwar
ist es ganz einfach und zwar fragen sich
immer so viele leute kennen
wahrscheinlich schon sehr viel weil es
noch immer viele leute beantworten aber
ich kriege immer noch so viele
kommentare und auch mails und
nachrichten als mögliche hey luca wie
machst du das du einfach im block hast
auf den du drauf guckt zum beispiel so
dass jetzt ein bier gab jetzt habe ich
in snow blog jetzt habe ich ideen habe
ich ein pferd ins bonhorst und zwar ist
es ganz einfach mittlerem aus dass die
käfer mittlere maustaste einmal drauf
drücken wenn ihr in den blog anguckt
dann bekommt ihr den wenn ihr wasser
cook funktioniert das nicht glaube ich
nicht funktioniert nicht dann wird er
halt der block darunter angewählt das
ist ein bisschen blöd weil ich finds
halt wenn man so wasser anguckt so habe
ich ja kein block im visier und cook
halten das wasser dann könnte ich ja
schon das wasser nehmen geht allerdings
noch nicht ich finde es mittlerweile
schön dass man auch die spanier dann
bekommt wenn man da zum beispiel fährt
sieht man bekommt halt einfach die
blöcke in dem anhalten mittlere
maustaste drückt und dann
bekommt man das tschuldigung rudolf
bekommt man hat ganz einfach die blöcke
die darin die sind da kann ich jetzt
überall mittlere maustaste machen welche
ich schon mal hatte dann geht mir das im
inventar angezeigt welche noch nicht
hatte bekomme ich geld zugewiesen und
wenn ich dann halt zu viel ab wenn ich
zum beispiel bin und ich bin da doch
dann wird das leben mitten im schwert
geht das allgemeinen gar nicht wenn ich
sage aber durch liegt darauf dann
verändert sich das aber mit schmerzen
gar keine sachen möglich auch wenn ich
hier drauf strecke geht nichts kaputt
okay wenn ich gedrückt hatte glaube ich
mich gedrückt halte geht kaputt auch
nicht es geht mit schwert nichts kaputt
im creative mord das ist was gutes was
ich sogar finde weil ich hatte damals
meine folge mit ozelot und da musste ich
nach alle zu töten und dann habe ich dir
meine halbe welt kaputt gehauen
also na ja heute mehr so eine
grundwissen folge von den mai kreft
facts ich hoffe euch jetzt trotzdem
gefallen wenn es euch gefallen habe ich
mich ist feng china zu regnet es regnet
hier einfach pausenlos in dieser welt es
wäre schön wenn ich ein schneefeld wäre
dann wird's ein bisschen schneiden aber
naja ich würde mich trotzdem freuen wenn
ihr daumen hoch da lassen würde wenn es
euch wirklich gefallen hat und ihr könnt
mir bitte weiter infekt 10 kommentare
schreiben die auch funktioniert ich habe
mir diesmal sieben facts rauszusuchen
müssen von den aber drei einfach nicht
funktioniert haben wir haben davon nicht
funktioniert habe ich jetzt als fun
fängt einfach den genommen schreibt mir
welcher in die kommentare die wirklich
in der 1.7.2009 wunderschönen tag ich
hoffe morgen kann irgendein video kommen
sonst werde ich irgendwas anderes
versuchen hoch zusammen mit dem handy
oder so weil wegen internet die witwe
scheint und sonst noch ein unterschied
bahrain bis zum nächsten mal